buongiorno tutti i mi chiamo stage
italiani e sono qui per raccontarvi la
storia di aids store un progetto di
biblioteca pubblica sociale innovativa
che hanno creato un quartiere a londra
ecco però questa storia dei bertola
voglio cominciare e raccontarvi una
storia piccola storia mi sa che
raccoglie questa importanza della
lettura e della delle presenze di
biblioteche pubbliche nel territorio
allora la mia storia parte da
dall'italia sono italiano nato a torino
crescita una famiglia cattolica come
molti in italia dove un certo punto
nella mia infanzia felice come infanzia
os x incoraggiato andare in chiesa dai
miei genitori
così per vedere come andavano le cose in
chiesa
ecco spiegato il tipo gli 11 12 anni e
ho avuto un po di difficoltà a
continuare a frequentare le chiese
perché non lo so io cercavo delle
risposte delle domande che mi facevo a
quell'età di e non riuscivo a trovare
delle risposte vere e proprie
casualmente in quel periodo può anche
scoperto che c'erano effetti una
biblioteca vicino a casa mia biblioteca
pubblica molto bella karina l'ho
frequentata e improvvisamente ho trovato
che in effetti molte domande che non
riuscivo a trovare in chiesa
le risposte ricevute le risposte nei
libri in questa biblioteca
a questo punto ho deciso ho fatto una
scelta e questo non lo faccio con tutto
rispetto per chi crede e leggeri di
essere le due cose sono compatibili si
può andare in chiesa si può anche della
geotec a nel mio caso ho scelto la via
della biblioteca e della lettura e poi
il presidente in questo senso la lettura
ha cambiato la mia vita e all'editore
pubblica ha cambiato anche la mia vita
in effetti poi oltre una serie di
circostanze nella mia gioventù per cui
in effetti non poi non ho finito gli
studi in italia gli o interrotti e non
sono tra università e queste cose qua
però sono finito in inghilterra e mi
sono trovato in un progetto molto
interessante che a che fare crowe
lettura perché si chiama ajdir store
allora mi sono trovato
in inghilterra a londra in un quartiere
di londra che si chiama tablet uno dei
quartieri più difficili ma anche il più
interessante se come molto molto misto
molti emigrati in molte classi sociali
diverse e molto interessanti problemi da
aams però qual era
e quello che avevamo delle biblioteche
di questo tipo tipo 15 anni fa dire
pubbliche di questo tipo che veramente
fatiscenti e non valeva la pena avercele
più che ci siamo messi io una squadra di
colleghi gli operatori achara cosa di
veramente diverso abbiamo creato
qualcosa che poi è diventato re di astor
basato su un concetto concepito grazie
anche al coinvolgimento diretto delle
popolazione nei fatti una grande
indagine di mercato
abbiamo chiesto la gente poi perché non
ci venite in biblioteca qui siamo nella
capitale inglese eppure non venite il
mio teca
e così grazie al loro contributo e loro
idee abbiamo creato una miscela di cose
che poi ha realizzato questo progetto
che si chiama leader store che e
comprende un sacco di cose che vi posso
elencare innanzitutto importantissimo
trovare gli edifici che siano quelli
giusti ben concepiti come posizione al
centro delle zone più battute della
città anche alcuni sono anche imponenti
questo dia destro white apple è il più
grande 3.600 metri quadri pure abbiamo
anche di quelli più piccoli come questo
tipo 1000 1100 metri quadri che sono per
dirvi che sono realizzabili non sono
delle cose delle cattedrali della
cultura irrealizzabili sono realizzabili
da qualsiasi città cittadina che si
impegni e voglia creare dei posti che
siano veramente vivi a 102 comunità
locale la chiamano improntati su un
modello commerciale nel senso della
parola nel senso buono della parola
senza delle idee e del design e del
effetto visivo anche per cui sembrano
molto più delle librerie di classe anche
che delle fatiscenti biblioteche
chiaramente siamo sedesse pubblico
gratuito per cui non c'è lo scopo di
lucro in questo abbiamo poi creato un
posto che molto molto
così abbastanza rilassato dove non ci
sono regole assurde che vietano di fare
questo questo costato per cui 12 venire
a prendere un caffè fare una commessa
sono il telefonino eccetera per cui
questo e compatibili stimo con con tutte
le altre attività più tradizionali
biblioteca secondo noi e poi possiamo
anche un sacco di altre cose per esempio
passiamo un sacco di cose circa 800
corsi attività varie che possono essere
la danza di tutti i tipi bollywood
africana eccetera
facciamo anche corsi di cucina anche li
facciamo incontri con autori poeti
filosofi insomma un sacco di cose
interessanti corsi di informatica per
tutte le età
facciamo anche corsi di cucito può
imparare a cucire a pasti i propri
vestiti facciamo anche un sacco di
attività per i giovani poi mangiando i
giovani poi riusciamo anche naturalmente
è importante accentrarsi i bisogni della
popolazione locale che molti dei quali
sono immigrati per cui loro devono
appena arrivo devono imparare la lingua
inglese per cui piace un sacco di corsi
di lingua inglese
facciamo stabile di attività per bambini
dai 0 ai 5 anni soprattutto tutti i
giorni facciamo un sacco di cose molto
moltissimo e poi ci spostiamo e
continuiamo ad attrarre bambini anche le
età scolastica come come vediamo e
coinvolgiamo gli anziani a volte
riusciamo a mettere gli anziani con i
giovani come questo progresso è progetto
internazionale in cui si parlava della
seconda guerra mondiale e queste persone
sulla sinistra agli anziani erano
testimoni diretti della seconda guerra
mondiale e parlano con persone molto più
giovani che chiaramente non poi ci
rischiano di un guerra mondiale
abbiamo anche una grande spazio per una
galleria pubblica una se una galleria
hard arte pubblica aperta a tutti
chiaramente è questo è un misto di cose
ma una cosa importante di mettere questo
misto di cose insieme è il fatto di
avere le idee chiare su cosa va con cosa
cioè su come mischiare queste cose
questo
a questo punto viene in mente di fare
questa se mi permettete un energia
culinaria e mediterranea nel senso che
mi viene in mente il piatto francese
famoso che si chiamerà teatri di piatti
di verdura e io ho sempre pensato che
era da cui si facesse in un certo modo
fino a quando ho incontrato un amico
chef che mezza maktum a non fare
rotatori io e te ma non so affetti e la
verdura ne metto in un pentolone con un
po di cipolla pomodoro
dopo un paio d'ore atera mangino no no
no non si fa così dal da cui veramente
si fa facendo cuocere le zucchine a
parte e poi fai cuocere le melanzane a
parte e poi i peperoni a parte e poi le
miss che insieme vuol dire che ognuno di
quegli ingredienti ha una sua identità e
riesci a distingue solo in questo modo
riesce a ad assaporare il gusto di ogni
verdura nel sesto senso l'energia è
questa che anche di astor facciamo mille
cose diverse
però ognuna mettiamo la cura che ognuno
delle cose è dovuta la dovuta attenzione
se passiamo una cosa per gli anziani
la pensiamo come cose per anziani per i
bambini per le famiglie e per gli
immigrati per esecutati insomma
cerchiamo di sempre pensare dal punto di
vista di ogni cosa la sua individualità
non è un pentolone assolutamente una
cosa importante è avere una squadra
dietro per realizzare questo sogno che
veramente crede nel progetto e queste
persone che fanno parte della squadra di
astor non sono i tipici dipendenti che
si trovano in molte espressioni
pubbliche in inghilterra ma anche con
italia sicuramente questo non è molto
portati all'interazione con il pubblico
sono molto dinamici pieni di idee e
hanno un certo potere di decisione e
riusciamo a farlo per questo risultato
qual è
visite in biblioteca quadruplicate
abbiamo la gente che fa la coda al
mattino questo all'apertura alle 9 del
mattino
andiamo alle nove di sera siamo aperti e
ci sono persone che partecipano in
questo senso a volte purtroppo purtroppo
è anche per fortuna
dobbiamo addirittura chiudere le porte
in una biblioteca per ragazzi come
questa quando il numero massimo non si
può non ci stanno più percorribili per
la porta che dispiace da una parte
comunque ecco
sono orgoglioso di far parte di un
progetto che veramente promette a tutta
la popolazione degli 0 ai 100 anni di
offrire qualcosa che abbia senso che
serva a loro nella loro vita quotidiana
che il gap che contribuisca la qualità
della vita in questo senso con quel
piccolo quel piccolino a sinistra e già
comincia a leggere ed a 0 ma
letteralmente andiamo fino a 100 anni
perché la persona sulla destra si chiama
max una presenza ma max max live id
persona molto importante del nostro
quartiere è una stilo utente di aids
store e è una persona che io ammiro
moltissimo a cui spero di rifarmi un
giorno nel senso che lui e un forte
passato di antifascista è anche però
anche un forte presente nei passista e
tra l'altro ha combattuto anche in una
una battaglia contro le camicie nere nel
36 a londra che molti non sanno che
esiste nucleo londra questi problemi
ecco lui è ancora un utente regolare
quotidiano o dia di astor e oggi io sono
qui a parlare con voi però in effetti mi
sto perdendo il suo compleanno dei 100
anni ero celebrerà ad editor classi